you
what is getting fuck this game well you
did it you bought the DVD good for you I
guess that means me have to give you
something a little extra don't we how
about all of you yes we all enjoy
reviews don't we now what should it be
mmm I know how about a video game a
really precious make up fuck off cuz
that's all you wanna say isn't it you
just want to see me be angry dance
monkey dance well waste no time beating
around the bush
let's just take a look at the game that
we humans used to call Blues Brothers
vanessab nowadays people like to call it
an unholy text arm of shit shades god
this game is awful the worst thing to be
associated with the movie since Blues
Brothers 2000 oh that's right I'm fuckin
right there what makes this game so
horrible what makes you want to give
yourself testicle surgery when I spatula
well I'm sure inquiring minds want to
know
let's take a look at the Blues Brothers
game first of all just look at the Blues
Brothers yeah they got their basic
likeness down but when did the Blues
Brothers fuckin smile would you think
the Blues Brothers were cool if they
walked around everywhere like this oh
well I guess I got a pink one of these
guys let's go ahead and pick Elwood what
rock'n'roll
really that's his battle cry walk walk
walk
sounds like Fozzie Bear feels trying to
go all metal Wacka Wacka Wacka Wacka
Wacka and roll so as you can see we
begin with stage one and oh yeah oh this
is exactly like the fucking movie yeah
with the spice the rotating platforms of
being set in the fucking foreign it's
literally like watching the film oh look
at that giant killer fees remember that
from the movie oh hey a giant spiky ball
on a chain remember that from the movie
what part of Chicago you think this is
supposed to be Millennium Park help
think up faces that you water at you and
it's not a stranger this shit let's see
you got to get to a tooth Bach sent
that's it that's the end of the level is
it the shortest stage ever played look
the clock starts off at 99 seconds and I
finish at 84 it's 15 seconds 15 seconds
the time it takes to put the game in the
system takes longer than that okay so
after defeating that epic first stage
you move on to the second stage where
you fight possessed killer lawnmowers
what exactly is the story of this game
anyway I mean it doesn't give you a
backstory just sort of tosses you in the
middle of everything I'm gonna trick the
instruction book cuz I gotta know what
kind of story has a possessed killer
lawnmower in it okay the Blues Brothers
are back to play the Blues on their way
to their first concert first concert
yeah cuz they're a little note startup
band they encounter a jukebox and decide
to listen to some good music but as soon
as they approach it they get trapped by
the evil machine finding a way out will
take the Blues Brothers through the
sewers warehouses and the suburbs of
many large cities okay are they in the
jukebox are they in the city cuz I don't
know that many cities they have spikes
on the ground and possessed killer
lawnmowers okay well maybe parts of
Cesaro but even then that's a big
stretch can Jake and Elwood escape the
hungry jukebox and reach Chicago in time
for the greatest concert of all time not
if I keep feeding us this bullshit story
okay so the idea of each level is to
reach the jukebox before the time runs
out which almost never happens because
each level is like a minute long at most
get it you're in a Jew box but there's a
jukebox inside the jukebox how are you
gonna get outside the jukebox if you
keep going inside but you box oh well
your main weapon is a bunch of records
you can like to throw it everything yeah
it's like that Aerosmith game revolution
X we're musics the weapon don't give up
open mind so much except they always
make this up a notch is sound every time
you collect around it sounds like
someone hit Sam Kinison in the balls
every time you get one oh if you want
these Kate's you suddenly become Arnold
fucking Schwarzenegger yeah I'm sure
he'd be happy to know that this game is
encouraging that eating sweets turns you
into a muscle builder you jump on
mushrooms throw records and shit there's
a lot of things about this game that
don't make sense I know I'll beg but I'm
talking about the gameplay itself for
example when you start off the game you
have a hundred of these records to throw
which makes it kind of pointless to
collect more for the 15 seconds of
gameplay you have but whatever it's got
the next level and then suddenly I'm
down to 50 but the hell where the less
my records go okay whatever I still got
fifty in a ton more to collect that's
doing bad look at all these I'm getting
at the end of this level I'm gonna have
plenty in the next one what the fuck oh
fuck tard why you gave it to me before
why the hell did you give me all those
records at the end of the last level
you're just gonna take them away anyway
what do you think I'm gonna do with
those records before and the frigging
level you think I'm gonna listen to them
but imagine makes sense but you're not
allowed to so it's entirely pointless oh
and just to make things more annoying
remember when they handed these things
out like candy before you couldn't get
enough of them in this level they don't
give you any until halfway through you
have no control over how many of these
you can keep you're totally at the mercy
of the crazy programmers who randomly
decide when you can defend yourself or
not and that would be too bad if you
know the fucking controls were easy to
use first of all every floor in this
game is like ice look how much you slide
every time you try to stop you have to
account for that every time you jump a
platform and sometimes they don't even
give you time to adjust just when you
thank God that you finally didn't slip
off and die what down you go
fucker damned what didn't go skating in
butter before he started this magical
fuck quest and the second thing is the
chains these fucking goddamn chains now
I know what you're thinking what's so
hard about climbing a chain all you have
to do is push up right no you have to be
at the exact point to climb these things
you have to push up at the exact moment
you hit that chain not a second later or
a second earlier and even then just like
the floors you can easily slip off who
design it that way if I want to go up
just let me go friggin up you know what
the fuck kind of factory is this anyway
all I ever see in this place is fucking
chains and boxes they're really putting
up electric shocks to protect chains and
boxes priorities in this magical jukebox
world are pretty plugged up got my balls
shrivel up every time I see one of those
chains look how close I was to falling
off there it's like they're trying to
give you wiggle room to move around on
the chain where the hell am I gonna want
to go except for up or down dad come on
chains
kids do yourself a favor find somebody
that works in the chain factory and plot
you don't explain why don't even
introduce yourself just punch him in the
fucking face God knows they want to keep
you in the factories long enough this
has got to be like the ninth level I've
come across that's a factory maybe they
want you to get a job there
look at this level they give you a less
time than usual cut this one let's go by
real fast
come on you fucking dog mo le on 16
seconds fuck I swear this gaem is a
sadist of expectations it gives you a
bunch of time it takes it away if it
gives you a bunch of records it takes it
away where the bugger masters day oh god
why would they give you such little time
when part of it is just waiting for
these fucking dogs to move fuck it I
don't care I'm gonna just accept my fate
hey it's better than giving them the
satisfaction of thinking I give a crap
of course I don't why it's a fucking
call so after you finally get past that
level you get to go outside the factory
it's still factory but fuck it at least
you're outside then after that you go
into another forest well good maybe
we're finally moving away from that
whole fucking Factory thank God dad I am
so sick of this place when they closed
down these factories do the safety
hazards what's this thing a flying snake
yeah why not I won't expect anything
else out of an everyday Factory in an
everyday magic jukebox so what the hell
am I supposed to do with it it just sort
of nudges me it doesn't really kill me I
guess I can grab it but when I throw it
it just comes back again
oh I ride it okay there should be a lot
of fun and it's kind of cool idea
oh fuck you if I touch anything I fall
what a lot of bitch okay this wouldn't
be too bad it really one except look at
it honey this is me what I'm keeping it
still it's always moving it's incredibly
hard to control everywhere I go it tries
to fight me or dock me off it literally
tries to head towards the nearest
platform to make you fall and look at
this shit
maneuver through fucking kidding me shit
shit shit hold still you asked out one
shit this thing is impossible it's
honest to god like trying to write a
real fucking dragon I guess I should
congratulate the game for trying to be
true to life except that it's a fucking
flying dragon cut me some slack KZ easy
goddamn it easy God oh I like this
obviously there's no way to get on and
without touching some sort of platform
so either way I'm dead it's really a
shame that this thing is fucking
allergic to walls oh come on I don't
like to say more than you do bitches
sores just come on god I can't believe
how long this is taking
it means you're just to find a real
snake and actually make them fly hell is
this thing anyway me see if it says in
the instruction book snake a friendly
creature you can jump on its back and
control it does that thing look remotely
friendly to you does it act like it's
friendly if it's so friendly how come
he's always trying to knock me off and
push me down every chance he gets
dah okay duh duh he pushed me he's
fuckin poised to me friendly creature my
ass nothing in this game is friendly
this is shit it's all shit one face
thinking fucking pile of fuck shit Oh
concert over I'll say it as
I'm sorry I couldn't review any more
that shit I mean that game is terrible
they had a god-awful game has nothing to
do with the movie the floors are made of
Crisco that the controls are insane and
he's terrible it's a terrible terrible
game and I pity the poor sucker that
comes across that game and tries to play
it
oh my god a video game do ass brothers
let's be friends I'm in the stache'
critic and God have mercy on his soul
oh my god it's exactly like the movie
keek makes you stronger I don't
understand baby
cloud noise sure is slippery isn't it
hey I thought I was beginning out of the
jukebox okay just go up the chain there
game and go with the G got the chat
oh no complaint sneaked can you play the
girl you keep watched me that's in a
band evidence day
I'm causing this or some other idiot can
find it boy what's this